imagine athletes stopping every time
they heard people booing them we're
talking [ __ ] while they were on the
court that's how I think about being an
entrepreneur like course or just living
life but just imagine that like you're
in a free Beltline on somebody enough
you just they cry or take the shot you
got your first TV face [ __ ] Carlo
everybody got drives to the car Ronnie
got a broad on is your lobby for the
Johnson teaming up with Chase huge
client of mine I'm sending you because I
trust you the most
this little survey got some surprises
for you leave your two cents on your
thoughts about where the content can go
[Music]
and then the other one for 130 hemp am
in their story and their uncle what's up
guys it's Gary be so fired up 137 p.m.
is finally live.com experiences here
swipe up get on it bookmark it sign up
own it feel it live it let's go lunch is
no time for judgment now for sure that I
won it won't settle federal past
opponents on have my [ __ ] strapping
corn this other half back and forth with
public housing unemployment we scream
live what up
it is now's the Tuesday after Labor Day
officially [ __ ] is real it's super
clunky for me like to get for me like a
true lover of work even for me the first
day back off the full extent of the
layaway is kind of like oh you know yeah
but I need that first meeting I've never
done the whole LA thing too you know I
need I need that first meeting
no no I'll have one here in a second
relax I just need to get going um what's
going on oh if your New York or New
Jersey the super tasting the wine event
October 8th you should definitely go to
Wine Library calm click the banner at
the top you'll be seeing a lot from it
tomorrow
I'm excited about that come drink some
wine with me that'll be fun going to
some meetings alright in my office out
here that's what I'm doing tip of the
day stop [ __ ] listening to anybody
but yourself outside noises so many of
them
imagine athletes stopping every time
they heard people booing them we're
talking [ __ ] while they were on the
court that's how I think about being an
entrepreneur like course or just living
life but just imagine that like you're
in a free Beltline and somebody not you
just they cry or they don't take the
shot all right I need to go and that
post I put in my stories about Twitter
is very real just an incredible place
for us to to jam see I took a break it
was R it was really good really good
time have you been I have to check out
see if I can make it from 11:30 to 5:00
yeah I have what 1143 yeah ready
okay looking good in your photo yes sir
man try to double tap that a couple
times okay love it everyone's camped in
Albury that's so awesome
how are you awesome and then let me go
check and see if it's available okay
okay thank you
what's up gang how are you well no word
hey guys hey Jeff hey Mickey how are you
brother
you guys are you guys get you guys are
getting into the real [ __ ] huh awesome
all right so you know I'm just trying to
get my bearings from all this stuff
obviously I'm just getting the three of
us aligned on any conversations around
media within the within the office I
think we're all talking the same
language I think the question becomes
let me throw out scenarios because it's
a very tight-knit circle if we if we
just one of the ideas I have is opening
an office and becoming vaynermedia and
me and Mickey do you know doing
something more entrepreneurial or if
Chuck every NGO or SMB or things of that
nature so I don't want to do anything to
to macro at the same token if
georgia-pacific comes in and wants to do
something meaningful or something else
brews just want to get a sense of like
just getting the three of us speaking
the same language
[Music]
all right opponents on thank you thank
you
[Music]